[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through its Philosophy by practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi I'm Dan Hayes I'm joined by my
co-host Dr Greg Sadler and today we're
talking about
rhetoric and Beyond and this is a little
bit of a reprise of an episode that we
did
two shows back because we took a little
bit of a what would you call it
discursus into interviewing carneades
about skepticism who will hopefully have
on against some other time to talk about
that we talked about his recent book
right right now we're coming back to
delving into rhetoric but we're gonna
we're gonna go beyond it we're gonna
talk about what else there is besides
rhetoric and what else did you have in
mind for for this Dan
so if the the main point of rhetoric is
that we are trying to convince someone
to believe or hold an opinion
um then uh there is the the standard
model that we talked about last week
with um Aristotle laying out the logos
ethos and pathos as main ways of you
know making speech in order to try to
convince someone one way or the other
but there are other ways to have
conversations and to actually change
people's minds without like directly
attacking these ideas in the way that
these three major ways uh tend to do and
you know you can maybe say like that
they're a little bit of of one thing or
other but they're they're all taking
kind of a
a secure this route to getting at this
thing without going directly at the
thing
um okay but if the end result is to
actually change someone's mind then it
doesn't matter the route that you get
there it's the one that is actually the
most effective
yeah and there's a lot of ways of
changing any given person's mind on the
one hand and I think on the other hand
we can also say that there are some
people where
for better for worse is very very
difficult to get them to change their
mind they're not they're not amenable to
persuasion or conviction or rational
argumentation or things like that I mean
a prime example of this which doesn't
completely fit this are the people who
are unconvinced of something until it
happens to them or somebody that they
care about or relate to like you think
about covid right for for quite a while
there were people that were denying
important aspects or facts or things we
could say about covert that that you
know the educated populace more or less
was booling to buy into without being
epidemologists themselves and
um they were you know oh no it's you
know none of this mask stuff is
important vaccines are bad for you blah
blah blah blah and then suddenly they
got coveted and they changed their tune
or they saw their kid or their parent or
spouse getting sick and going to the
hospital and suddenly they cared about
it in a way that they they didn't before
so I think there's a lot of people
probably like that not just with that
particular thing where until it hits
home with them or there's a story that
they like they can relate to it doesn't
do that much for them it's kind of like
you know somebody else's problem
and it absolutely is this idea of
relating to things and this is actually
one of the things that we'll get into
later
um is a way to
um
talk to someone that might be totally
outside of your group and still be able
to relate to them in a way that allows
them to potentially see your uh story as
uh a valid one
something that they could take into
their little universe
right right exactly
um and
um also you know just as a short reprise
what do we we were asking last week was
what is rhetoric good or bad and it
really comes down to the the way that
you're using it and for what ends you're
trying to get to and so
um this this is also going to carry on
for all these particular techniques is
uh what what are you trying to do with
it are these for good ends or are they
bad ends
you know I'm I think that the ends thing
is completely correct but I think we
could also talk to some degree about
means
um you know you you could have a good
end
um you know like let's say you just want
people to like each other and not be
mean to each other or something like
that that's a pretty good end I mean
there's some people maybe that we should
be mean to but let's put that aside for
a moment right
um but you could try to use very
coercive or manipulative or deceptive
means to get them to do that like you
know and it doesn't have to be all that
um terrible you could like tell them
some story that's completely false about
somebody who was bullied and ostracized
and try to make them feel bad and and
this is a you know a completely made up
story that you presented as if it's true
I would say that even though there's a
good end in sight maybe the means it
doesn't turn the end bad right the end
Still Remains good but you do have to
watch the means that you're using and I
think with rhetoric we have to be pretty
careful so like maybe we have to check
in every so often to see whether we're
lying to ourselves about
whether we're being overly manipulative
or straying over certain lines what do
you think about that means and
distinction thing there
well I think that comes down to a lot of
the types of rhetoric we see today
and especially we just
um we completed another election season
and we had a whole bunch of rhetoric on
the TV and the radio and on the internet
everywhere he went on and a lot of it is
uh using you know our pathos
specifically fear and
um the question is how much are you
willing to demonize another person in
order to win your race or how much are
you willing to use uh people's uh
bigotry and prejudices in order to you
know put forward or Advance your
candidate what what are the the things
that you'll pay you know to actually get
that power
yeah and sometimes this can be verbal
and in other cases it can be visual you
know like I think we're all familiar in
commercials there can be sound aspects
here right so they'll have like a it's
in color the candidate that you're
running against and they're like I don't
know cuddling a poppy or you know
tussling some child's hair or something
like that and it's almost like there
used to be this show called Tales from
the Dark Side back in the 1980s and it
began with this guy talking and it was
kind of like an idyllic scene
Countryside you know and I forget
exactly the wording you can you can look
it up on YouTube it's it's a really
great intro sequence this guy's talking
about you know most of us live in the
sunlit world of what we take to be
reality and then suddenly everything
starts turning darker and it's not like
negative you know where all the colors
become exactly the opposite but it and I
don't know how they did this special
effect but it must have been like a
really Advanced thing back then now we
would just you know type in a few things
on our video editing software but you
know like the scene turns dark and the
music gets kind of warped and scary
sounding and then the announcer who's
got this deep voice is like but there is
also a dark side unbeknownst to most of
us you know and it's just as real you
know but not as brightly lit right and
instead what they do with these
candidates are they like well you know
Mandela Barnes looks like a really good
guy but now it turns to like black and
white and like the the image skews a
little bit and the music comes in you
know he kicks puppies throws them down
the well or they do this with you know
whoever else right it's kind of you know
I mean you almost know exactly what's
going to happen when you see the first
intro frames because it's such a common
technique and it's there specifically
like like you were saying it's appealing
to pothos which means emotion and the
emotion that it's appealing to you if
it's not fear it's usually another
negative emotion like disgust or anger
or
I suppose you could say Envy in some
cases it's usually not like let's appeal
to happiness you know
um I guess I'm going to uh quote a Yoda
here a Fearless anger anger leads to
hate hate leads to suffering
um which is interesting I feel like you
could get fleshed out if you actually
want to use this as like a full thing
but it's a good like stepping off point
of like yeah you're
um you're using this path Osteo fear and
and anger which leads you to like uh I
want to do anything to do to stop this
person
um yeah and and that's a strong
motivator and so this is actually you
know one of the reasons that this is
actually a really bad technique to use
in order to actually persuade someone
that's not already on your side it's
much more useful to take a person who
already agrees with you and rile them up
in order to actually get them out to
vote and so a lot of the campaigns are
moving towards a you know um you know
the electrode so split
um and very closely so that's it's not
about persuasion it's just you know get
as many of your voters through the polls
versus the other yeah and you know I'll
say two things one is I think you're
right about that the polarization as we
typically call it has changed the scene
in American politics certainly
especially here in Wisconsin where the
margins are so so thin right and
um a lot of times it's not just the
candidate who's being attacked it's the
other side's voters don't let those
people control things you better get out
there and vote because otherwise they're
gonna you know get get what they want so
there's that and I think the Yoda quote
is actually I don't know about the
suffering part I think maybe that comes
in at every single point but fear does
lead to anger pretty predictably so you
make people scared with your rhetorical
appeal and people don't like to be
scared so then they they much prefer to
be angry because anger feels like an an
emotion that I can hold on to and use
yeah it's got agency right it's more
active whereas fear you know you're
pushing yourself back and a lot of
people are very invested in that and
feeling like they're not fear driven
that was another thing with the covet oh
I'm not going to put on a mask and give
in to fear you know and you're like
you're afraid of putting out a mask who
are you trying to fool you know but then
you know another interesting thing is
anger
um does lead to hate and this is
something that gets noted by a lot of
different thinkers including Aristotle
Aristotle in the rhetoric says one of
the causes for hate which is
qualitatively distinct from anger
is anger if you feel angry at somebody
over and over and over again there's a
tendency to like Veer over into this
other modality of emotion and you know
anger um doesn't want to completely
destroy the person it's angry at hate
Aristotle tells us this is way back in
2300 you know plus BC he tells us that
hate ultimately wants the object of hate
not to be not to exist so hate wants to
efface and wipe out the thing that's
here you know yeah yeah exactly
yeah yeah and he brought up a couple of
other things that are also on my list
here which is the in-group versus out
Group which is a very strong
um yeah yeah uh patho space uh reasoning
um and then the other ones that I put
down here are are
um the you know optimism we saw that
really well done with uh or the Obama
campaign the whole yes we can and it was
incredibly optimistic of like those
things yeah I hope yeah
so like the the policy was it was a
little bit thin there it was a lot of
just like you know hope and change and
you know what does that actually mean
um and then the other one that I saw a
lot this year was um shame
uh and there's a lot of like things that
were trying to get people to go out to
the the polls and says uh your your vote
is uh Secrets but if you went and voted
is public record will your friends and
family and neighbors uh think better of
you if you don't go vote
so there's another you know pathos type
argument yeah actually it works people
really dislike it but it actually works
that's why people do it
yeah I mean I do think that there are a
lot of ethos based appeals but they tend
to be false and so ethos means character
right and
um I mean Aristotle says well you should
try to present yourself as being a
certain kind of person so the audience
will believe you and he actually names
off three qualities I don't see this as
a an exclusive or comprehensive list but
he says you know if you want to be
believed to be acting in good faith you
know an interlocutor that could be
listened to you need to
um possess you need to look like you
possess you don't actually have to have
it but you need to have something that
looks like virtue right so you need to
look like you're a decent person in some
respect
um you need to look like you have what
the Greeks called fronasis or practical
wisdom or Prudence so you're not a dummy
right you you know if you're going to
make policy proposals you actually know
what that hell you're talking about your
proposals aren't stupid you know you
take into account uh new factors but
then he also says that you need to have
what the Greeks called unoia which means
good will so you need to at least appear
like somebody who cares about the people
they're talking to and this is where
like Barack Obama and Bill Clinton were
really good at that sort of thing
um you notice like Hillary Clinton very
very smart
and actually looks like you know she was
a pretty decent person but it didn't she
didn't have that part down you know
people didn't trust her you know the
question is how much of that was her and
how much was that of like in 20 years of
negative
that's right against yeah yeah well and
and so yeah ethos is not something that
you can yourself completely control and
and I kind of think that most of the
appeals in politics about ethos are at
best like half truths you know I mean
they're always like oh so and so is a
successful businessman and you're like
well let's actually look into this you
know what are the what happened in their
business oh there were like sexual
harassment suits and they overcharged
the state for things anybody who has
done their research knows which
candidate I'm talking about here you
know one of those who lost this time
around right but I mean what's being
presented there is like you know
something that sounds really good
successful business person or it could
be you know person of Faith or it could
be what are some other ones
um I'm a military veteran oh that's a
huge one right yeah I mean anybody who's
been in the military I think if they're
smart they don't automatically trust
veterans because they're like I remember
the stupid you know uh terrible people
that I served with some of whom you know
there were some really great people that
I served with and then there were people
that I would not trust with a penny you
know so
yeah
yeah so um oh go ahead so trying to
continue on just a little bit like you
know with the you know what the other
rhetorics that we have currently
um there's there's almost no logos at
least in the last couple years you know
there's not a lot of policy positions
that Gary putting out here it's not
saying like hey vote for me I'm gonna do
this it's it's been very much
overwhelmingly negative just like the
other party bad uh
don't vote for them vote for us or the
policy positions that are being put out
are primarily there to appeal to emotion
and they're not they're not like real
policy proposals very complex you know
covering all the bases making a good
case for what they want to do or I mean
I take that back I I would say that that
you know the Democrats actually often do
bring that stuff out and that
everybody's bored by it and they they
don't get super excited you know right
the Republicans they'll bring out a
policy and it'll be some you know think
about the um don't say gay bill you know
uh down in in Florida right very
straightforward you're not going to be
allowed to talk about homosexuality or
any lgbtq stuff I mean there's an
argument there it's it's pretty much a
bad argument based on uh premises that
are very doubtful but and it's it's
functioning less is like an argument and
more like an emotional appeal you know
yeah it's it's
once somebody think of the children
exactly yeah yeah so it's using not just
an emotional appeal but a Trope yeah
something that got made fun of by The
Simpsons like 20 years ago that's
exactly what I was thinking about yeah
yeah oh what's the the pastor's wife uh
doesn't matter yeah yeah yeah
um but they also will use uh policy as
an attack it's like oh my opponent will
um do x y and z are like you know take
away your rights let the criminals out
tax you to death right yeah which are
like proposals but they're like negative
proposals and so it's very like oddly
twisting of like you know vote don't
vote for me because I have proposals
that you'll like it's don't poke for
them because those have those dangerous
proposals that we've told you are bad
you know and something that is often
left out of that
um and it's good that we we exist in a
um culture where we can actually like
track the things down so you know people
were going after uh Governor Evers in
this last race about oh he's too soft on
crime you know he's letting these people
out on I forget if it's like furlough or
parole or something like that and then
other people pointed out well you know
Under The Walker Administration which
Evers you know ran against and and
defeated Scott Walker
um there were even more people like this
so if you're complaining about this but
you didn't complain about that what's up
with that and it's it's sort of a I
guess you could say it's pointing out a
fallacy that we could call hypocrisy or
selective memory you know
um but there is an awful lot of that in
political rhetoric and I think we could
say there's a lot of that in in other
types of rhetoric too right
um
when um you know we're constantly being
pitch products right
oh yeah like it's
hard because this car
Volvo like that's boring stuff I'm just
like you know buy this car and like all
the women like you and like uh
as well like
there's all sorts of like it's
cool by association a lot of the time
it's like oh like you know just get like
really really famous people and they
drive your things like oh well I want to
be like Drake and Drake drives that so
um I want that or Drake wears those
shoes you know what car manufacturer
really has tapped into both Pathos and
Ethos is a Subaru yeah you know they've
got those ad campaigns where like um I
mean to begin with you're going to have
your Subaru forever so there's that part
and I guess that's kind of a logical
appeal but it'll be like you can pass it
down to your kid and you see like the
whole vignette like so you know little
kids hopping in the car and then you
know they're like tweens and then
they're teenagers and then they get to
drive the car and then you the ad is
handing over the keys to his daughter
she's going off to college or something
there's like an entire story being told
there and that is very successful
rhetoric you know yeah
um but this all comes back to certainty
or beliefs and why that we actually come
to them and so um there's a neurologist
on by the name of Robert Burton who did
as
over a decade worth of research on on
psychological triggers for why we feel
uh certain about things because the it
comes down to we feel the same way
um or we feel the same certainty when
we're correct as when we are incorrect
yeah there's the confidently Incorrect
and so here's a little blurb about some
of his work
certainty argues Robert Burton is not a
conscious Choice nor a thought process
but is a sensation that can be described
as a feeling of knowing as a feeling
like anger or fear certainty does not
rely on any underlying state of
knowledge what this means Burton argues
is that we can be wrong even when we're
convinced we're right as an example
Burton describes the Challenger study in
which a group of students were told to
write down their experiences of feelings
right after the Challenger explosion
happen and then asked to come back and
recall their their thoughts immediately
after this
um three years down the road they were
very confident all of them about what
their feelings were at the time and then
they went back and looked at their
Diaries of their own handwriting
and a large proportion of them
confidently believed that their Diaries
were wrong and that their memory was the
correct recollection of what happened at
the time yeah that is and I actually
remember
um being in the classroom when
[Music]
um we they wheeled in the TVs and we
were we were watching it and
um it was supposed to be like this
triumphal moment I think it was because
there was a teacher on board that's
that's why it was supposed to be such a
big deal and then we're watching it and
you see it like start to fall apart and
the you know the smoke and and we're
like you know the the vast
um majority of the responses I think if
I remember back to it we're not like oh
so horrible Collective grief or anything
like that it was like what are we
watching what what the hell's going on
here
really and interesting yeah
um
but I think that there's a lot of
narratives right you know oh the nation
as a whole like for my generation That
was supposed to be the JFK assassination
moment seeing the Challenger blow up but
it wasn't I mean it I I think that was
basically in like news reporters heads
who wanted to have some sort of
interesting analogy to draw you know
um now now there's one other thing I was
going to say about this too I mean
Burton is saying something that uh
philosophers like David Hume have said
in the past that you know that this what
we call belief is in when you think of
it as cognitive I believe that XYZ is
the case but it really is a matter of
feeling more than anything else
yeah
um
was it the um the passions or sorry the
uh the intellect is always the slave of
the passions is that the quote he he
said that reason and he and he's
overpriced because like just a couple
lines later he almost disproves this in
the same same thing but he Hume was a
great rhetorician I mean this is a great
line reason is and can only be the slave
of the passions right
um yeah he's he's the guy who coined
that that good phrase there Hume is a
really good writer stylistically but
that doesn't mean that he actually knows
well he does know what he's talking
about but he doesn't always present it
in the best way you know he he can't
resist um
sometimes making it sound better than it
is you know so this comes down to if we
don't consciously make these decisions
about what we believe or what if we even
feel certain about the things that we
supposedly believe yeah then
or what is the best way to potentially
change one's mind if it's not like oh
I'm going to think about this really
strongly I'm just like oh I'll figure
this out or or have a good conversation
with a good interlocutor you know a
honest person that you're having a
dialogue with what is the process to
actually do this and so it's oh well I
was going to say if you think about how
people rationally
approach situations where they're not
quite sure and they need to figure
something out so like like take the
example of buying a car right
um you could do that in a lot of ways
you could just like walk into a
dealership and let them exercise their
rhetoric on you and you walk out of
there with a car that's probably not
good for you
um or you could like get consumer
reports and like check out all the
different stuff and and that's that's
much more logical right
um sooner or later you still have to
consider things like well
should we get a minivan should we get an
SUV should we get a you know four-door
depends on what our needs are going to
be you know and there's a lot of things
that maybe are we going to have 15 kids
well then we need a minivan you know and
maybe a trailer are we going to have two
kids uh maybe we can get by with just a
four-door and car seats or something
like that so there's those kind of
rational decisions you know like where
are your kids going to go to school what
are you going to major in these things
could be dealt with pretty rationally
right yeah and then you have questions
like
is my spouse cheating on me or not like
I'll bring this up in my class and talk
about epistemology and I'll be like
epistemology can be about very
day-to-day things like you know your
spouse comes back from work and their
hair is all messed up and they're
they're their clothes are buttoned up
weird like you know they're not they're
not exactly the way they were when they
came home and they kind of smell like
somebody's perfume or cologne or
something like that right and now you're
like wait a second what the hell's going
on here now you got it now you're like
thinking about wait didn't I see like a
phone call come in and they took it off
in the other room and you start bringing
all this stuff together right and that
can be done in a very rational way but
most people don't they bring in all
sorts of emotions and you need to have a
conclusion soon you know you gotta you
got to figure this out right or it could
be anything else like am I going to go
to prison for this thing I did or you
know any anything that could like bring
in our emotions
we we we're just we're still operating
in a semi-rational way but we're also
being driven by our our passions
right and so
this comes to exactly the the next topic
here of you know
one of the things that we are able to
actually make rational choices about and
what are the things we're not and so it
was very uncommon to have someone change
their mind over there's even some small
things if they're important to them and
it's even more Uncommon to have people
change their minds on something that's
strongly held and so these are any
beliefs that serve as the foundations
for their roles in life and
um these things that they can't give up
without the consequential consequences
of an existential crisis and so some of
these things are
you know what are the your ideas of what
good and bad are on is the world just
believes about on what is natural for
humans beliefs about like what political
party you're for on your sports teams
affiliation and like what religion you
believe are true and all these things
yeah people will build their entire
lives around and if you were to if they
were to lose these beliefs they would
have to like re-evaluate everything
about or a lot about of what they
believed and how they were even going to
interact with the world on a day-to-day
basis I think it's very interesting that
you've got the sports teams in there
because you know most of these things
like oh is the world just okay big
metaphysical and ethical issues what's
natural for humans right uh which
religion is true what political party
those all sound really important right
and you should you'd think that like
sports teams ah you know that's that's
Entertainment that's not that important
but people do get like super super
attached to that you know I I am uh and
I think I may have mentioned this on the
air before I am both a Packers fan and a
Bears fan which is kind of a rarity in
either state of uh Wisconsin or Illinois
and there's you know like a whole story
that I don't need to rehearse they're
basically my my parents moved up from
the Chicagoland area yeah to Wisconsin
you know like to watch both teams we had
you know memorability memorabilia and
cops from both teams and so I just grew
up that that way right
um but a lot of people are like you have
to pick one you know and I'm like no I
don't have to I just hate the Vikings
instead you know I reserve all my hatred
for them but you know think about this
when people lose a sports team right
um because you know franchises move from
place to place that's a huge blow people
aren't sure where they should be putting
their whatever it is that we we have for
for sports teams into you know so when
like the Colts move from from uh uh
Baltimore to Indianapolis or when the
Rams were moving around they went from
LA and then they were in St Louis for a
long time and then they went back to I
think back to L.A straight back to L.A
yeah yeah
um now who are the St Louis people
supposed to root for they've got to kind
of figure out you know yeah
[Music]
I mean Baltimore got the Ravens so yeah
and then what uh the Browns became
something else and then they got the
Browns back or they the new French the
Browns became the new Ravens I think
right oh yeah and then the Browns became
the new Browns right
um so
coming back to like these beliefs and
these things that we really hold uh dear
we we have a lot of
um
a neurology science and experiments with
um the we know which portions of the
brain light up when we are filling in
physical Danger
and these same portions of the brain
light up when uh people try make
arguments against these deeply held
beliefs because this is
self-preservation portion of this brain
and these ideas are
so important that you have now
cognitively put them into I need to
defend these things just as I need to
defend my arm from being bent off by a
tiger yeah and so when you try to use
redder to try to change someone's Minds
on things that they hold dear they'll
and you go to at them directly you know
this like throw more information at them
that's trying they just throw up walls
because one their information is coming
from someone that they
perceive as a potential enemy and two
it's attacking this thing that is
foundational
on
uh so it might also they might also
treat it as if it's kind of trivial I'm
thinking about like the religion and you
know like the Christian atheist polemics
that were really big on social media in
the early 2010s or all this stuff about
apologetics I mean very few people I
think are actually convinced by
apologetics one way or the other because
it's like you know a logical appeal
um and you know as soon as somebody is
like taking the opposite team and
starting to produce their arguments
you're like yeah there's probably going
to be something wrong with this
somewhere right right right right you
get a super super skeptical uh to the
point where nothing is going to even
make it through your filter yeah
um and I'm I I want to say one other
thing all right I'm always deeply
suspicious of people and I'm a
philosopher right so I should be all for
rational arguments I'm deeply suspicious
of people who wind up being convinced
solely by rational argument or say that
they were you know and like abandoned
Faith or took on faith as a result
to me I always think there's something
else going on in the background
you know well you're very you're very
human then
yeah I'm human in that way yeah
um
and um I guess one of the extra things
is that people carry their opinions and
their beliefs with them and so just
because people say like oh you know just
give them the data
um it's always being filtered by their
their own brain and they have certain
different values that you might not hold
as strongly as they do and so they're
they're going to make their decision
making from a totally different place so
the question is is rhetoric dead if
people hold these strong beliefs and
none of this straight up rhetoric
um can actually break through this
barrier for the very strongly held
beliefs
um is there any point or is there
something else
well what would be doing the job of
what rhetoric does which is to tailor
appeals to particular audiences in
you know pretty thoughtful sophisticated
ways that we can we can teach people how
to do I mean we do this in classes that
are called rhetoric but we also do it in
communication classes I think you can
view salesmanship as largely applied
rhetoric you know right
on but like selling someone a car is
different things like I guess people do
go around and proselytize but the the
direct prosthetication is not usually
the the thing that's going to change
someone's mind there
um but yeah obviously rhetoric prison
debt there's lots of applications
especially for the straightforward just
as you said
um
uh but you know for certain things that
you you can't go a direct approach and
you have to have maybe a circuitous
route
and I think that um
there are a lot of people I mean if you
go on like Twitter or you go on
Instagram or anything that's kind of
visually oriented you're going to see a
lot of people talking about Aristotle's
you know three main modes of appeal uh
logos ethos pothos but then when you
look at what these people have to say
about it's clear they all they've done
is like copied it and pasted they don't
know what any of these things mean or
they can talk about it in a very vague
sense but they're not they're not really
master
rhetoricians or theorists of of rhetoric
and part of the problem is that
um you know Aristotle okay we're talking
about more than 2 300 years ago why
would we possibly think that like he
exhausted the totality of ways in which
we appeal to each other right right or
if we you know add other people in
Cicero cicer it was great you know he
adds some new things to the uh to the
picture quintillion there's all sorts of
great rhetoricians running all the way
through to uh you know the 20th century
um I mentioned last time that I'm I'm a
big fan of uh kaim Perlman and ulbrix
tatekas a new rhetoric and that's much
more comprehensive but I'm sure there's
stuff they they forgot and left out
right right so so I think that when we
say his traditional rhetoric dad some
people might take that as does it cover
everything that we could possibly want
and the answer is well why the hell
would it right right so what are the
other things
and some of these are
um you know in-group thoughts and yeah
social creatures
um we often believe things because it's
required to be part of a group if you
want to be accepted by Packer bands you
have to like the Packers if you want to
be part of the Mormon church so you need
to accept the Joseph's fist was a
prophet of God these are kind of like
really base ideas that if you don't
believe these things then you're like
then why are you here yeah yeah go
someplace else
um and um and when we the the flip side
of that is that when we lose these
beliefs we also lose our membership to
these groups and we as social creatures
are incredibly worried about the idea of
being ostracized or removed from the
group you know uh
we can lose family or friends you know
there are certain religions that will
um break all contact with you if you uh
leave the group or leave that religion
and that's you know a really strong
motivator for you to maintain those
beliefs
um and it's an incredibly strong like
motivated reasoning to like well I
believe this because otherwise I I lose
my mom and my dad my sisters and
brothers
yeah I mean and that can also happen in
families even without like you know you
could call it religious overlay
interfering like if um I don't like take
a situation of abuse or exploitation you
know or even just parents that didn't do
a particularly good job and like you
know the parents are very invested and
oh we did the best that we could and
there's a couple kids who buy into it
and then one kid goes to therapy and
they're like holy crap my family is
messed up right and now I want to talk
about it they they can sometimes find
themselves being
um pushed out as a result nobody wants
to engage in discourse with them you
know so I think that's that and that can
happen too like in workplaces or
um I mean if you were working at Twitter
right now and you're like oh this
takeover was just amazing you know it's
it's just like Blue Skies Ahead
um I think your fellow workers are
probably going to be like
are you getting paid for saying that
right
um and then you know another added a bit
to this whole thing is you know the uh
Exile especially for a lot partition of
the human development was synonymous
with death if you ever got kicked out of
the group especially at a terrible time
that was you know a high likelihood
you're going to die so you have we have
this really strong ingrained you know
more than just like I feel bad because
people left me but like it's very close
to that that fear of death
so
um
there's and there's also a number of
other newer kind of like more
comprehensive systems I assume there's
going to be even more as we continue
learning on but a couple of nice ones
are on a heuristic systematic model but
this is by Shelly chakran and Alice
e egly and so people are motivated to
hold correct attitudes uh correct
uh means and self or self-serving or
group serving reasons
um belief is based on reputation
management so a confidence Gap exists
between when you hear a new idea and a
new idea actually coming and you
accepting it by uh the ideal by a
heuristic of
if they're in group peers will accept
that belief so you're you're at the
philosophy department and you've got a
new idea are your philosophy professors
going to uh agree with you how much
extra work you have to do to make sure
that they would actually agree with your
argument versus like you know some
random group of people on the street
I think it's unfortunate to say but uh
philosophy departments are not the place
to go to find the most rational human
beings you know
um I mean I could I could see this like
you know in terms of the fads that we
have or like this is this is the way
that you do philosophy and you're like
this isn't the only way to do philosophy
I can go down the street to another
University with a different department
and they're going to do they're going to
be like more amenable to these ideas or
different authors or different different
approaches and you know how how much we
can like draw on psychology or economics
or other other fields right it's it's
not as if there's like one single
philosophy line but you often do see
this in departments where they're like
this is the way philosophy is done you
know and I think you see this too a lot
in business right where business people
are they they've got one particular
model of how they like to do business
and they think that this is the way of
course Corporation should be structured
or this is this is how HR should work or
stuff like that and they um you know if
you disagree with them
you're going to have a hard time
right
so this comes to
um
you know eventually
uh asymmetric what I'm calling
asymmetric rhetoric which are a number
of techniques that are have been
developed in the last you know 15 years
for I'm kind of going at uh trying to
change people's minds from a less direct
way in a circuitous way and so these two
why why is it asymmetric rhetoric
what's the asymmetry in it
um because if you're expecting to have a
conversation in the way that most
rhetoric happens you're having or you're
just even having a dialogue you're like
okay I'm going to present my evidence
you're going to present your evidence
we're going to argue about the evidence
we might argue about premises or like
structure of things and
um this goes no not going to talk about
that we're going to talk about something
related but not the thing so it's over
here and so uh asymmetric in that one
person is expecting one thing from the
other conversation and this is kind of a
different way to go about the same end
goal but it's not the same okay
that makes sense these two are deep
canvassing and Street epistemology
um so so canvassing when I hear that I
think about people going door to door
that is exactly it okay so most canvas
thing goes like you know knock on the
door are you gonna vote for this person
yes or no and like do you know it's
election day yes or no you know great
put the little check on your list and
you go to the next door
um I think it's like you hey you should
vote for you know this person or this uh
proposition and that's kind of it okay
you might have a couple talking points
I've done canvassing
um but deep canvassing is a a strategy
by which people try to engage
um their interlockers of the people
they're talking to in open conversation
and ask them their views so it's not
like hey you should do this these are
arguments to do this thing this is I
want to have a conversation it turns us
into a potential like antagonistic
relationship into hey I'm just another
human being here I want to know what you
think and so it automatically changes
the conversation from an um an
argumentative position or an adversarial
con position into something that's more
um
constructive
okay so so this could be done as like
actual canvassing going and knocking on
people's doors right right there's a
have you ever
um gone to a death cafe
where people walk in and it's basically
you have unstructured conversations you
walk in and there's like tables you sit
down at a table and then
um you talk about your views on death
you know and it's supposed to be fairly
non-programmatic like you're not
supposed to walk in there and be like
let me tell you about what I know about
the afterlife you know and uh you know
there's a good place and a bad place you
want to go to the good place well you
got to accept Jesus in your heart none
of that sort of stuff there right it's
more like well what do you think uh you
know then then you can get into well why
do why do you think that sort of thing
and you know I've only been to one but
it was It was kind of cool
um I mean when Once people find out that
you're a philosopher either they really
want to talk to you or they don't want
to talk to you at all you know so it's
kind of tough to do with that I suppose
it's like you know if you're a lawyer
and you walk into certain contexts you
know but it seems like the the
conversational approach should be
similar to what deep canvassing looks
like so could that be like an instance
of deep canvassing uh
not exactly because there's a couple
more steps to it so the first thing is
you're asking them about their views but
it's about a particular topic and so
this started out with I believe it was a
gay marriage was one of the first places
where they they started using this and
they're like okay
go in and they're like hey tell me about
your your views about gay marriage you
know what do you think positive or
negative I'm kind of like why do you
think this thing
um and then you engage in active
listening
um and then you're going to share your
personal experience to connect with
their points of views and so you want to
listen you want to like repeat back what
they say so they know that you're
actually listening to them that you're
not just on a script
um and um a lot of times they started
off this with people that were actually
like LGBT plus
um in that they and then there's like oh
well you know I I met my partner and we
love each other just the way that you
talk about like I guess I was talking
about like marriage like what do you
think about marriage and whatnot yeah
and then they would say they would make
a uh they would take their their story
and and find the places that was similar
between their story and the person that
they're talking with and say like oh
you're just like me
um and so now they were already in this
place where they're like sharing their
views and they're the things that they
really like about this thing yeah yeah
and that's like hey well why shouldn't I
have that same exact thing
um
and um and then you that's the third
piece here is to give perspective and
highlight commonalities
um and Alternate viewpoints
um and so they at first they thought
they had to have someone that already
had like these life experiences
um to do these canvassing but they've
actually found that you can
um do this with people that don't have
these experiences but relate to people
that they know
um and it still does a very good way of
process by which we can go and um
put it into a story that they can see in
a non-threatening manner
um and a way that also relates to them
well that's interesting I mean that
sounds like it could also involve some
you know traditional rhetoric or
storytelling as well right so it's not
like incompatible with older approaches
it's sort of like an add-on yeah or an
overarching structure that you put it
into yeah and and so I guess just from
the if you you're kind of making the the
rhetoric as this narrow like I'm gonna
like you know have these arguments you
know kind of like you know set up and
whatnot I'm gonna like kind of debate
you these are very different and and
this one as well as the street
epistemology both start with
um you know making it so you're not a um
an adversary that we're we're here to
have a enjoyable conversation so walls
don't go up
um so the next one do what do you do if
you're in one of these formats and you
get somebody who really wants to be an
adversary like they've got old ideas
about this or they just get a kick out
of like I love to debate people that one
of those kind of people do you just
say well we're not going to do that here
or do you like kick them out or do you
try to work with them well for deep
canvassing people are actually going
door to door so I'd say instead of
kicking them out you probably just leave
if they're that that have a cereal
you can't kick them out of their own
house
but if
you have techniques to try to get people
back on track and I'm trying to have a
conversation with you
um oh I want to know what what you think
um uh and try to get into that mode it's
uh that's the place where you actually
get benefits yeah I suppose in that way
you can say listen I value hearing from
you I I do want to know what you think
and so you're you're bringing some
incentive to them to play nice so to
speak right
So speaking of that now we have Street
epistemology and this is actually the
one that I'm most familiar with
um because I've used this a number of
times and so this is a way of talking
about a thing as something you brought
up earlier epistemology how do we know
the things we know yeah so this is uh
has a number of steps to it on
so uh I'll just go to step one so we're
gonna you have someone that you you want
to talk about something that they
believe and so you as before we
establish Rapport and inform consent hey
would you like to have a conversation
um hey like I'm really interested in
what you believe and why and most people
are really willing to share the things
that they believe especially that's
something they strongly held me most
people want to share that
um
and um
you want both the people to be happy and
enjoy every part of the conversation
there's this you know obviously once
again non-adversarial
um and so it's really important to set
up good rapport
and so then you
um
be friendly Small Talk Chit Chat like
you'll get to know the person a little
bit before you even get into this like
hey you know how you doing are you
enjoying your day here on if you're like
at a grocery store I don't know you
could like say like hey what you picking
up or something I don't know it depends
on if you want to go out and like engage
someone or if you want to have people
come up to you or you can put like a
sign it's like hey I'm done for
conversation it's kind of like this uh
death cafe thing you know people are
there for the conversations in the first
place so
so it's not like the meme with the guy
who sets up a table and then go change
my views well it says it'll like there
will be an assertion that he's like
changed my mind you know yeah it's not
adversarial like that right no no it's
very much like
um I'm not even gonna hold a belief I
just want to know about your beliefs
um okay and we'll talk about your
beliefs and things that you you care
about
um and so then um you try to identify
the claim
um and
um
and then we're going to find a
confidence level this is actually uh
optional
um approach but this is useful if you're
like new to this excuse me if you're new
to this approach
that um
is this the thing that uh
you'll agree you're going to ask us
again at the end of it of their their
confidence level and to see if like you
did change their their confidence in
this belief in the first place
um and once you have that confidence
level you kind of um
uh you as continue to ask about the
claim itself and
um identify
and clarify the main reasons and so you
know we we had to identify and clarify
the claim
um because sometimes the claims are a
little bit muddy and then we had to do
that uh try to you know uh clarify the
the reasons because these are also
potentially muddy so you want to find
like the one that they're most
um
strongly believe this thing for and so
we all have lots of reasons that we
believe the things that we believe and
we want to find the epistemological
reason why they do believe this thing
and so if you can kind of hone in on
that thing then we ask
um
to identify and explore the epistemology
and so we take this thing why did they
believe this and say we look at the
epistemological reason someone believes
that thing do they believe other things
for the same reason do those reasons
always lead to True conclusions do other
people use those same reasons and come
to the opposite conclusions as yours
and so a lot of times people will will
have things that they might even be
totally true but they believe them for
the wrong reasons because the reasoning
is not sound
um and
um if you find one that has bad reason
you go like oh hey let's let's talk
about this why why do other people
believe other things but they use the
same reasoning
um if that's not a good litmus test then
what are the other things that we can
use to try to reinsend this and find a
better reason to believe this thing
because you know a lot of this is about
trying to find true beliefs and
um what can one do to work through that
so if you if you find one that gets
knocked down you go back up to four and
you find a new reason
um and tell either there's no more
reasons or you find a good one that
actually holds up to scrutiny and then
you end the conversation or you can end
it before they actually you know go
through all these this is most people
don't change their mind about anything
from a single conversation
yeah
um you know there's not a lot but you're
inventing seeds right you're you're
priming them for
um changing their minds down the line
right
um and and I think just people should
have better epistemology for the things
that they believe anyways like I I want
to believe true things and um
I I would like other people too too
um so but you want to end the
conversation on a really friendly note
you know the whole idea here is that
we're supposed to be both enjoying this
so that we're not being antagonistic on
you're not the idea is not to win the
argument make the other person feel bad
on
uh but to try to hopefully people have
better reasons for the things that they
believe
um and you know you might find that
these conversations also can change your
own mind
because maybe you were believing things
for bad reasons as well and you know
they bring up the same things
I like the idea in there about the
conversation is supposed to be enjoyable
or Pleasant or engaging right yeah
um because I've heard people you know
talk about Street epistemology in the
past and I've never like really paid
attention to except what I pictured were
like guys going around and debating with
each other and
um trying to like you know one-up each
other stuff like that but this this
sounds completely different yeah you
know this one very much actually could
be something fun you know it's
collaborative right yes
um and I've seen people do like
interesting things with like UFOs or
Flat Earth or you know uh I should be a
Democrat or I should be a republican all
these ideas that we hold
um yeah or that like you know
um whatever budget you could be mundane
things like you know I think we should
spend more money on X or Y you know okay
all these things can be uh investigated
with this particular tool and then you
can have post conversation stuff like
you can say hey do you want to have this
conversation again or something because
once again as you said uh it usually
takes a number of conversations to
actually get there and maybe bring in
additional stuff right uh in a new
conversation or you remember things that
you should have talked about before
we've all had that experience of thing
oh I should have said this right yeah
now I think we better wrap up because
we're pretty close to the end of the
hour do you want to take us out on a
final thought yeah also we leave you
with the words of Lee McIntyre you don't
convince someone who doesn't base their
beliefs on evidence by providing them
with more evidence
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]